you showed up with one cause you thought
he was gonna wear one right i was
worried so when i talk right and i'm not
done with a sentence you don't wanna
start yours hey okay because what does
that mean that means you interrupted me
okay and then what all the words get
jumbled together
i don't like the way you're talking to
me and put your hands don't put your
hands at me i'll move my hands no i'll
move my hands okay those hands look
sharp
dude
when i'm talking you want no part of me
and the words go think it okay
there's a rhythm now you're doing it now
ding it ding it ding it ding at the
thing and then you come in
where's the thing at the thing of that
it's lost you know what you don't do
chris him with the oops yeah i do hold
on a second do it no i do do it hit him
with luke don't do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i would say brian should make that
but it's never gonna happen
so you do it right yeah do the uber
grenade you'll sell it yeah
i'm gonna do it dude you know what brian
i'll tell you right now if you made
merch right if you made merch
if you made merch
and you said i got hit with an oops
grenade you'd make thousands of dollars
thousands yes you would
you won't you don't give up
yeah he's teaching you the fish right
now i'm going to do that i'm going to
make tank tops